what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and we are really and
truly in the final phase of the boku no
hero story the stage has been set for
what will probably be the final showdown
the battle for ua and everything seems
to be falling into place on top of that
toga's infiltration of the ua may have
just been foreshadowed oburo's return
may also have been foreshadowed and
endeavour was wearing a fedora for some
reason so let's get into it if you
enjoyed the boku no hero videos on this
channel and you want us to keep it going
you know what to do just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it helps with the algorithm and if
you're new to anime uproar or maybe you
watch our videos regularly but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications before we get into
it a quick thank you to dislight for
sponsoring this video dislight is a
brand new pop fantasy rpg with striking
visuals and outstanding characters
collect and train your espers form teams
and strategize your way to victory in
this epic turn based rpg fantasy i love
the stunningly vivid art style which is
inspired by both pop culture and anime
and the world of the game is just so
cool you get to play in this colorful
futuristic world where certain people
attain divine powers these humans known
as espers must come together to save
humanity from an earth-shattering threat
the divine power that awakens the espers
comes from gods who are based on various
mythological traditions including
chinese egyptian greek and norse
mythology just imagine ancient divine
spirits in a futuristic urban setting
how freaking cool is that
check it out for yourself by
pre-registering for dislight right now
it's totally free and since the game is
brand new getting into it right now will
give you a head start on the competition
just click the top link in the
description to pre-register right now
for free and if you do you will be
supporting this channel at the same time
so check it out link in the description
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned we ended off last time with
kota and the big furry girl running up
to deku and embracing him after ochako's
big emotional speech kota and the furry
girl are people whom deku had directly
helped in the past and in order to help
them he had to put his own life on the
line as i said in my previous video
these two running up to deku and
embracing him accepting him in front of
the entire crowd of anti-deco protesters
would likely make the crowd think twice
after all two people who were inside
that crowd owed their lives to this man
named deku so if these civilians are
willing to vouch for him then he must be
a true hero someone who's there to
protect civilians not put them in danger
the new chapter starts off with everyone
crying again mineta thinks that maybe
they need to run to deku and support him
but ida holds him back ida says that it
isn't their place to do that and what i
think he means here is that the crowd
already knows that deku has the support
of the heroes and hero students the
crowd now needs to see that deku also
has the support of normal civilians like
them people like koda and the furry girl
at any rate everyone is crying including
minata ida ochako kota deku furry girl i
mean it's either they're crying or the
rain is falling right into their eye
sockets as our boy roy mustang would say
once kota reaches deku he apologizes for
not coming out to support him sooner it
looks like koda was so scared that he
couldn't move and it was only after he
heard the furry girl say that deku had
saved her that he summoned up the
courage to act then in a very symbolic
moment koda says to deku i am here and
he tells deku not to cry anymore in one
sense it is of course paradoxical that a
kid like koda would quote all might
almight was the strongest hero who said
i am here when he was about to beat down
a bunch of villains and save the day
meanwhile koda is just a weak kid with
tears flowing out of his eyes and he
also appears to have snot flowing out of
his nose like yes i get it he's a kid
and he's emotional but it's also kind of
gross anyway the fact that kota is
quoting all might here sends a powerful
message kota obviously isn't going to
save deku by overpowering the villains
he is saving deku just by giving him
emotional and moral support and that's
kind of the main message of this whole
arc strength and power alone aren't
enough to make someone the greatest hero
deku tried to rely on his own strength
alone and it didn't work he just
overwhelmed himself exhausted himself
and nearly got himself killed deku
cannot do everything on his own so he
needs the support of his friends and
loved ones in some cases that will be
direct physical backup by fellow heroes
but in other cases it will just be moral
encouragement or a shoulder to cry on
human beings need to have that human
connection with others they need that
system of support and a sense of
community and that is what coda and the
furry girl represent in this chapter and
speaking of the furry girl she proceeds
to pick deku up off of his knees and
raises him up so that he is standing
once again she then tells deku that she
had tried to enter many shelters but she
was refused because of her mutant type
quirk mutant type quirks are quirks that
permanently alter their user's physical
appearance in this case the furry girl
is very large and she has animal
features and this makes her different
from most other humans because of this
unconventional appearance she was being
discriminated against the paranoid
general public is seeing villains around
every corner and because this girl's
appearance is so different from the norm
she was presumed to be suspicious based
on her looks alone
this kind of reminds me of the racism
themes and other mutant-focused media
like x-men but the funny thing here is
that it's not even about super powers or
quirks per se since the vast majority of
the population in mha has quirks the
discrimination isn't affecting all of
them instead the discrimination here is
only affecting the people with mutant
type quirks because of their unique
physical appearance and yet when you
think about it many of the most
dangerous villains we know don't even
have mutant type quirks so singling out
people with these quirks is completely
pointless this is obviously a form of
racism or discrimination but
unfortunately it also makes sense based
on what we know from our own world when
there is some sort of massive crisis in
the world like a war or civil war or
anything like that people tend to become
paranoid and they start being suspicious
of everyone who is different than they
are this is not a rational response we
obviously know that someone's physical
appearance doesn't determine their
personality and yet discrimination and
stereotyping often begins to occur in
times of crisis the same type of thing
is now occurring in the world of mha as
the hero society descends into chaos and
as the villains let loose on the
population with that said though the
furry girl is grateful that she was able
to get into the ua shelter and she
thanks deku again for saving her she
also calls him crybaby hiroson which is
honestly so accurate the furry girl is
being emotional and memeing on us at the
same time and that is pretty epic furry
girl then proceeds to hug deku in front
of everyone and this leads to some
people in the crowd second guessing
their decision to reject deku one man in
particular says that they could at least
hear deku out since the heroes don't
have enough manpower to fight off the
villains anyway is throwing strong
heroes like deku out of the ua the
smartest thing to do for the people who
are sheltering there we have to remember
that during the previous arc a bunch of
heroes died and many more were injured
and then after that arc a large number
of heroes decided to retire because they
couldn't handle the chaos that ensued so
now when heroes are needed the most
there are far less heroes on duty than
there were before the heroes are
seriously understaffed so much so that
they are desperately asking for heroes
from other countries to come to japan
and help them with all of that in mind
is this really the time to be kicking
heroes out of the ua shelter wouldn't it
be smarter to help them to rest up and
recover so that they can be at their
strongest in case the villains do attack
after all the villains may be after deku
now but they certainly won't stop being
villains if deku is out of the picture
one way or the other all of these
civilians will eventually suffer at the
hands of the villains if they don't do
something to stop them right now that
same man then explained something quite
profound he says that up until now the
general public was just the audience who
watched the heroes performing on stage
they sat back in awe as the heroes
handled all of society's problems and
kept everyone safe at their own expense
all might was the prime example of this
the strongest hero and the symbol of
peace whose vigilant presence made
everyone feel comfortable and safe and
yet as i mentioned in my previous two
mha videos almight also set an
unrealistic standard for heroics and he
lulled the people into a false sense of
security the people thought that if they
just sit back and enjoy the show the
heroes will continue to do their thing
and keep them all safe forever but with
the collapse of the hero society the
stage that the heroes performed upon has
been swept away the people are no longer
just spectators everyone has been
affected by this chaos on top of that
those heroes who were in it for the
money and fame all bailed after jakku
and so the only heroes left now are
those who are truly brave and virtuous
the ones who became heroes to save lives
even if that meant sacrificing their own
life in the process that same man then
urges the crowd not to reject the true
heroes who are still there fighting for
them if they reject people like deku
they will have no one left to protect
them once the villains do come knocking
on their door and again this is a great
point this man really knows his stuff
and it would be pretty funny if he
turned out to be toga in disguise but
either way this man is spitting we then
see deku with tears in his eyes because
of course he has tears in his eyes
proclaimed that he is no longer alone
and that he will do his best to give
these people back the normal lives that
they had lost as even some of deku's
biggest opponents in the crowd seem to
break down in tears we are led to
believe that the crowd has now come to
accept deku which if true would be a
major step forward in the story as would
of course deku's comment that he is no
longer alone the focus of the chapter
then shifts to other heroes commenting
on ochako's speech and its aftermath
including hawks endeavor shoto and
ectoplasm endeavour is worried that they
really didn't make much progress when it
comes to shifting the burden away from
deku because the crowd will now expect
deku to defeat the villains and bring
back their normal lives in return for
letting him stay at ua but hawks does
believe that progress has been made the
people are beginning to realize that
everyone is connected that everyone is
in this together and that is an
important development this is no longer
the kind of world where heroes rescue
everyone and civilians merely observe
everything from the sidelines in a time
of unprecedented chaos and a historic
hero shortage everyone will have to work
together everyone must take
responsibility both hero and civilian
alike
we then jump to nezu i guess facetiming
izawa who is recovering after injuring
his right eye and losing his right leg
during the battle of jakku nezu tells
izawa that his class pulled off what he
himself was unable to do they succeeded
in reaching out to the angry crowd and
getting them to soften their stance
aizawa is clearly very proud of his
students and he goes on to tell nezu
about kurogiri it is then confirmed that
kurokiri did not break out of tartarus
during the villain prison break because
kurogiri was secretly transported to
another location and he is currently
being experimented on in an attempt to
reach oburo shirakuma oburo is of course
izawa's childhood friend who had been
turned into the nomu known as kurogiri
by all for one and ujiko if obero had
not regained consciousness for that
brief moment in order to warn everyone
about the hospital it is likely that the
hero raids would not have been as
effective as they were and the villains
would have caused even more damage to
the hero society isabella believes that
because he was able to emerge if only
briefly there is still a faint hope that
obero can retake control of his body
sometime in the future i did a whole
video recently explaining the obero
kurogiri situation definitely check it
out link in the description and in that
video i speculated that obero's ability
to briefly regain consciousness signals
the possibility that he could eventually
return permanently this chapter seems to
further encourage those types of
speculations but we'll have to wait and
see the chapter ends with izawa
mentioning toga and nezu explaining that
the ua has anti-toga countermeasures in
place this includes letting evacuees in
only after a certain period of time has
passed because the heroes are assuming
that toga's transformations have a time
limit so presumably if they wait long
enough any potential toga transformation
would revert back to her original form
before she was allowed to enter the ua
grounds isawa then confirms that the ua
is a stronghold and that now is the time
for revenge but the very last panel
shows a somber looking almighty standing
out in the rain with the text the rain
still pours written on the side which
seems to imply that the hero's troubles
are not yet over and that is how this
chapter ends and let me say right away
that this mention of toga was no random
coincidence as you will recall we saw an
image of her in the last chapter during
ochako's speech and now she's mentioned
again by totally different characters i
think that this is foreshadowing that
toga will infiltrate the ua if she
hasn't done so already don't forget this
important detail the heroes are still
not aware that toga's quirk had awakened
during the my villain academia arc
because toga didn't really do much
during the battle of jakku no one saw
her new found abilities and if toga's
quirk is now able to copy the quirks of
the people she has transformed into
meaning that she has gotten a massive
power up then it is totally possible
that once her quirk was awakened she
also gained the ability to stay
transformed for a longer period of time
nezu and the other heroes are going off
the information that they had about
togasquirk before her awakening which is
exactly what curious had been doing
before it backfired on her spectacularly
thanks to her massive quark awakening
power-up toga might already be inside
the ua in fact she might even be that
man who so eloquently made the case for
letting deku stay we know that toga
wants revenge for what happened twice
and we know that the villains want deku
to stay in one place so that they can
come get him we also know that the story
went out of its way to break down the
specifics of the ua's new security
system if we take into account the
concept of chekhov's gun the fact that
the story included a detailed
explanation of the new security system
at ua means that the security system is
likely going to be tested by the
villains at some point in the future
chances are that the villains will
attack the ua at some point and that is
where the final showdown of the entire
series could take place and if that is
the ultimate plan for the story then
having toga infiltrating the ua makes
perfect sense especially since she did
so little during the entire massive
jakku incident i was honestly surprised
by how small of a role toga played in
jakku but if her plan was not to draw
attention to herself so that she could
infiltrate the ua later then that would
make perfect sense at any rate here are
the major developments that we got in
this chapter as i see them first we have
the confirmation that deku now knows
that he has to work together with others
and second we have those anti-deku
protesters finally appearing to accept
his presence at ua then we have the
brief references to obero and toga some
might think that these mentions were
very brief and therefore unimportant but
i believe that they are actually
foreshadowing for future events i think
that obero really could regain
consciousness once again maybe even
permanently and i believe that toga will
become relevant in the story very soon
my guess is that she has already
infiltrated the ua and that her role is
to set the stage for the final showdown
of the series which will take place at
the ua itself but let me know what you
guys think did you enjoy the emotional
elements of this chapter and do you
think that the mentioning of toga and
obero were important foreshadowing or
just passing references finally why was
endeavour wearing a fedora i need to
know if you guys enjoyed this video and
you want to see more in the future do me
a favor and leave a quick like it only
takes a second but it helps a lot and if
you're new to anime uproar or maybe you
watch our videos but you still haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram at animeopror
thanks again to dislight for sponsoring
this video check them out link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you